foreign
question of the day comes from Harry and
Georgia he says I have a budget in place
and I'm using the debt snowball would
you recommend consolidating all of the
debt into one giant personal loan I also
have a total of fifty thousand dollars
between five credit cards a personal
loan and an appliance loan I also have a
ton of equity in my home so I was
wondering about doing a home equity loan
which could give me tax savings on the
interest should I just keep it status
quo for now and continue the snowball or
do debt consolidation loan overall I'm
just looking to expedite debt
elimination all right
so
the debt snowball I would not call
status quo I think that it is the most
effective way
um to pay off debt and it's been proven
there's been some studies I know Harvard
published a paper about why the debt
snowball actually works and that it
works it's the most successful way to
pay off debt so I would not recommend
um Harry doing a consolidation or a
HELOC and I I it sounds like you're just
like trying to think of ways to get this
debt out of your life and again there's
no easy button you're gonna have to list
your debts from smallest to largest and
work to pay this off if you do a debt
consolidation loan there's a couple of
things there you're not paying it off
you're just clumping it all together
moving it all together and actually
there's studies that show that when you
do that your brain thinks that you have
less debt and you go back into debt
again because you've moved it all into
one payment you haven't actually paid it
off not to mention when it comes to debt
consolidation you know they're doing for
you what you can do yourself they're
they're making deals with these
companies you can do that you're
yourself you can set up payment
schedules you can do all of that
yourself you don't have to pay somebody
to do it for you and a lot of times the
interest rate when you get debt
consolidation is no better because it's
based on your credit and if you have
ruined credit then you're not going to
have a better credit rate on that debt
consolidation loan anyway a better uh
interest rate
so I wouldn't do that and then talking
about the HELOC again you're just moving
debt and now you're moving it into your
home mortgage so you really want to put
your home on the hook for your debt I
would not do that home equity line of
credit is what he's talking about for
somebody who's listening the first time
that you don't understand what that is
it's basically a line of credit that you
pull out on your home and uh he wants to
use that to pay off his debt a terrible
idea you're not paying it off you're
just moving it into your mortgage not a
good idea let's use the debt snowball
again list your debt smallest to largest
make minimum payments on all of the debt
and then take any and all extra money
that you can and throw it at the
smallest debt until it's paid off gotta
go quickly gotta use intensity for this
and then when that smallest set is paid
off the money is freed up and you throw
it on the next smallest debt and then
you do that again and before you know it
you've got a nice snowball going and
that is how you pay off debt and let me
tell you something you want to do that
you need to do it smallest to largest so
that you feel those wins uh Harry
because when you feel the win of paying
off that smallest debt you're going to
be like wait a minute wait a minute I
can do this this works and then you're
going to go to the next one and you feel
that motivation once you begin starting
and once you start feeling the momentum
that comes with the snowball so just do
it just walk yourself through the
process you're going to be better for it
you're going to allow yourself to feel
the pain of your debt when you do the
snowball you feel it because you have to
work to make it happen you're not just
rolling it into some other loan you're
not rolling it into your mortgage you're
not taking the easy way out
Harry the thing you got to remember is
this
you have a block of debt that's fifty
thousand dollars
if that block of debt is a debt
consolidation loan it's still fifty
thousand dollars
if that block of debt is a HELOC it's
still fifty thousand dollars
there's only one way to get rid of fifty
thousand dollars
pay fifty thousand dollars
there is no none of these programs all
they do is lower the amount of interest
and interest is not your problem
spending more than you make is your
problem
not increasing your income enough to
throw at the fifty thousand dollars
is your problem
you need to come up with five thousand
dollars a month for 10 months
because you work so much that you can't
breathe
great place to go when you're broke to
work the interest rate on your HELOC is
versus the interest rate on your debt
snowball is not going to fix the problem
no you need fifty thousand dollars
that's the problem you're concentrating
on the wrong end of the iceberg
the interest is just sticking up above
the water there's a big Iceberg below
the surface 50
000 dollars that's the problem and I
want to write off the interest
as a having a HELOC you're not riding
off the entrance
you don't you don't write off the
interest on a HELOC you know why only 13
percent of Americans itemize
87 percent take the standard deduction
good point so you probably are taking a
standard deduction which means you don't
get to write off the interest because
you already took your standard deduction
if you are one of the 13 WHO itemize you
probably are not itemizing this this
anyway and it's not that big a deal I
mean the interest let's say it's ten
percent off fifty thousand dollars is
five thousand dollars you know what that
saves you in taxes 1250 bucks 1250 bucks
isn't your problem right fifty thousand
dollars is your problem quit trying to
trick your way out of this come up with
fifty thousand dollars that's how you do
it and the debt snowball leads you
through that process and keeps you
moving but you've got to concentrate you
need five thousand dollars a month extra
for 10 months or twenty five hundred
dollars a month extra for 20 months and
that gets rid of your problem not a
little bit of savings on interest or
some full tax write-off that you're not
even really taking because you're taking
a standard deduction that's what's
really going on